six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's try our caller from the 901 area
code call her from 901 go ahead David I
want to ask about how you thought about
James gun being fired over his her
Suites joking about pedophilia and
racism sex but I just want to be here
Kira talks about it
sorry who was fired for pedophilia James
gun you know the director of from
guardians of the galaxy I had no idea
this is the first I've heard I don't
even know who that is and this is the
first I've heard of it jokes about
pedophilia not oh well
what's guardians of the galaxy I mean
I've heard of it I have no idea what it
is that a movie is it a TV series I'm
sorry it feels like it's been it's been
like really like all over the social
media
I missed out on this but um it it's
pretty much a Marvel superhero movie ok
that's why I would go yeah but James
Gunn's
jokes about pedophilia very very graphic
and inappropriate jokes about pedophilia
and and sexist and racism drugs about
about nine years ago and nine daeun no
no about nine years nine years ago okay
say how old is this guy and all he think
he's like 50 now but and Disney hired
him in 2012 but um but just recently a
couple weeks ago Mike assertiveness
you're aware of him oh yeah right yes I
am um so he went back in James Gunn's
Twitter feed and brought up the feed
jokes about pedophilia yeah and racism
in sexist jokes
and that ended up getting James gun
fired from Disney so right do you think
that that it didn't he made the right
choice and I know this is probably he
probably had to do more research at this
listen oh I can answer it as based on
the information you've presented here's
the bottom line
Serna [ __ ] tried to do the same thing
with sam cedar finding a comment that
was very obviously satirical about Roman
Polanski from like five years ago
and it
temporarily got him fired from MSNBC
like what was it six nine months ago at
this point I don't remember
and then MSNBC decided hey you know what
this is this was like clear satire I
don't know I can't say whether Disney
made the right choice for them they need
to make they're obviously legally they
can do it they can use whatever is not
illegal they can't fire them because of
his religion but if they think that this
is not a relationship a business
relationship that's good for them they
can get rid of him I questioned the
value of what Serna [ __ ] is doing quite
frankly because it just is a way to
troll and to try to interfere without
actually changing like if if I felt that
Serna vich doing this was part of some
broader efforts to improve conditions
for women on social media and in
employment then I might say okay I
understand why he's going and do that
doing doing this it seems like just
destructive trolling for some people
it's costing them their jobs for Sam it
didn't but ultimately Disney's got to
make the decision that's right for them
yeah you know I I'm not a fan of sort of
it at all and I you know I I do agree
with you I I do agree with you about
seeing cedar but what James Gunn said I
felt probably I'm I don't think Disney
probably should have hired in the first
place but I thought the day they were I
mean I feel they were like 10 times the
amount of what Roseanne said I mean even
though I know that Rosen said it right
then he got fired but yeah don't anal
dungeon but even though their old tweets
I felt that James Gunn probably should
have I thought that they were just not I
mean if you look I don't want to say him
on here but I thought that they are a
bit too graphic to really say I got
listen I'll look them up I can't without
knowing what the comments were I can't
really say but that that's my initial
instinct and I'll try to find out you
know what guardians of the galaxy is
over the weekend if I have some time I
appreciate the call I am out of time
I am apologized for everybody I didn't
get to but we will take calls again